quella tutti ragazzi venuti avessero
video sarò fa vj ed oggi siamo tornati
su slitte rio con una novità pazzesca
non sapevo esistesse sta roba me l'avete
detto voi i commenti a esiste una mod di
slater io che è in grado di aggiungere
ti delle feature se vi faccio vedere la
simo ciabatta che ma portato culo
l'altra volta arrivato primo questo nome
non si sa come proviamo a fare una
partita normale con i sluyter io vi
faccio vedere che cosa ho scoperto
allora praticamente prima cosa ce lo
zoom
cioè tu puoi vedere la gente che sta già
e già questo ho capito come cazzo va ad
arrivare alla fine grazie al bene
anch'io ci riesco così non è vero non
c'è un sacco di altra roba tipo c'è il
tasto per restaurare c'è il tasto per
uscire che prima o poi dovetti dalla
pagina a saperlo prima è che a saperlo
prima non entravo qua dentro di mortacci
mia quanto stupido vuoi cambiare il
background bellissimo per fare un botto
di roba coi gatti fammi vedere il grand
prix gatti di prego piegano ma cos'è ma
vabbè sesta la ma dall iter you crepa
non è vero non è vero
no raga non avete visto questo l'ho
ucciso io non è vero facciamo normale
perché se non vedo punti non vedo una
mazza solo lo zoom uso solo lo zoom e
ragazzi tutti i seguenti punti vabbè ma
sono troppo forte tu valore me lo so è
quello che me li ford quanto lo su chi
quanto lo posso fare questo i miei punti
brutto deficiente erano miei mi sono
solo ripreso quello che mio non sei
tranquillo no vabbè lega sta partita a
partita del secolo ve lo dico
c'è rinunciare invece non ce li faccio
dire di un capo darà molta gente non c'è
nessuno vai vai vai prendi tutti punti
che culo petto quanti punti ho preso
ragazzi ancora voltas acquisì luca che
credo io che culo ma do come mi sono
salvato regalo il nuovo duckling lobo
non ce l'ho fatta di morte ma come ho
fatto a morire così ma dai che quello
che quello che quello che guardi in mora
che questo non è morto è brutta
deficiente come puoi pensare solo di
potermi uccidere morte volta portava i
punti di odio di odio di odio pan non è
molto pi chiara grossissimo solo
uccidevo vieni qui vieni qua
combatti da uomo era certo non sai
combattere mango buca la ragazzi non
riuscirò mai più di quanto già è invece
si sono uscito non ci posso credere che
culo no dai
ma lo sa il sito sono crepe o quanta
ansia in questa vita che crei favore il
cavaliere proprio è molto presa dal
secondo era in mezzo tra il secondo e
l'ottavo non sollecita ucciderne uno
nell'altro
o forse sì ma lezione dai laiche crepa è
morto cos'è successo
cosa se c'è una bella a questo gioco
succedono cose non ho neanche capito io
cos'è successo va ben 5000 punti forza
riuscì prima che questo ci inglobi
infatti arca vacca è morto pesca dai
basta cercare di inglobare c deficiente
oddio no mai toccato è matt o'connor
agam ha toccato no quante volte mi sto
salvando in questa partita quante volte
anche provento barlow che per rinnovarlo
non sono riuscito
che culo che culo che culo lo zoom così
magari no no bastardo volete ormai su
campo
tron e compenso ti uccido non è che
magari questo è il quarto perché dovete
pagare il pene a me se siete tra i primi
perché scemo tutto ciò che tu briaco
chiamo nippo io ti odio brutto
deficiente me ti ammazzo io tanti saluti
anni fa uccise un altro a caso vai vai
vai vai mai detto che era per i tre
quarti
che botta che volta live ai baila
vecchio di che gli chiudo tutti tutti i
miei punti questi tutti i miei si è
accorto che sei rimasto chiuso dentro si
dica potrà stacco seduta vita sto
stronzo è morto volo sopra senza motivo
e va bene dai perfetto o le 11.000 punti
classifica
non so in classifica a si sono pieni
vedere da il primo che va a sbattere fra
il primo che va a sbattere perde armi
pari non ero pronto non vale hai vinto
tu sei stato più forte per un arcobaleno
perché l'arcobaleno fa sempre figo bello
figo ma come la casa diventa tutto
pixelloso quando togli lo zoom ogni
tanto capita non so perché va beh sono
figo lo stesso cioè qualcosa da dire e
mi stai giudicando è nato come l'ha
ucciso
ma questo è successo non è vero non può
mai essere successa questa cosa sul
serio
veramente non so anche descriverla st
scena cioè culo che culo pazzesco e va
bene quanto culo a a sono io questo mi
chiamo pensavo fosse un altro ucciso
anche questo sono forte ma dopo ucciso
tutti senza un motivo preciso
solo quarto a caso sono guardano dai
ragazzi possa arrivare primo possa
arrivare prima o sei ore prima perché
prima non ha un cazzo di punti me la
gioco bene questa laiche sono quinto
quarto così dai forza così se riesco ad
ammazzare questi se riuscissi a farcela
tipo così
minchiate ne sia accorto
ce l'ho fatta mai bye bye bye varie che
dico primo arrivo primo vivo primo ma
non ci credo
la classifica tenterò classifica 7000 e
8000 [ __ ] macca secondo secondo te
che deve morire il primo può morire
prima per cortesia parlanti punticino ma
niente è la lotta per il primo più
difficile che abbia mai fatto
dai dai dai dai tutto questo odio 9300
2003 9200 2005 vagone è la 9700 ne ha
sempre qualcuno in più di mezzo bastardo
come li trova ma come fai a trovarli li
stai comprando forse non arrivò prima
adesso mi incazzo 10.000 non sono prima
non ci credo come cazzo li sta trovando
quello davanti a me i punti dove li
trova il mercato del pesce non potete
aspettare un attimo che arrivavo prima o
poi mi supera v.no e dei meriti
deficiente non li trovava i ragazzi
adesso l'obiettivo no è l'obiettivo
ok l'obiettivo è quello di battere il
record non so se ce la farò ci prova che
sto proverà ad uscire il regno e membro
dei pooh pare tutto no no devi stare
fermo di vista referendum storia ferno
che ti ingloba anche la sorella da ho
detto io il mio record ragazzi e poco
più di 20mila tipo 22 no dai ci proviamo
e fan su un campo ma io penso io penso
io lo zio quanto siano 16 mila moto non
è morto ma ucciso pure lui che penso a
riprendersi punti ma non li prende
brutta deficiente a bastardo ma fottuti
l'altro mi accontento di questi quando
siamo 18.000 quasi 19 mila ragazzi
quello pensa di averlo scampo ma non ce
l'avrà perché io lo uccido li uccido
tutti
vai vai marello inglobato inglobato ce
l'ho fatta bello resi come stai
mi spiace non dico la verità però dovevo
doverosi grosso mi servono i punti dove
ucciderti sorry for a quanto si sta
tenendo poverino dai come come fa a
resistere più di così non potevo fare le
gare dopo li ingloba ingloba tutti
perché pensano è al grandissimo fan non
è morto quanta gente sta inglobando
forse mi carica quando si quando si
grosso grosso può inglobare chiunque
parte che se n'è accorto prova bastare
inseguirmi è rotto il cazzo pam chi ha
avuto la meglio è brutto deficiente
contra grosso tra niente ora devono duri
a morire incredibile ragazzi mi sono
dimenticato di dirvi una roba della
quale stare attentissimi che quando
inglobate qualcuno tipo adesso rischiate
di essere inglobati pure voi perché più
semplice per gli altri colpirvi quindi
attenzione quando succede questo qua
giallo e mostra provando a fare cosa
ma non ce la farà
l'attenzione che gli altri possono
inglobarli più easy tipo questo
non ci riesce soca perché non mi ha
girato perché non mi agiti giuro che
sono andato all'altra parte mia andato
dritto perché orca ladra [ __ ] stava
fa un discorso serio per una volta nella
vita e fa un discorso serio niente ai
ragazzi figura di merda tanto per
cambiare sono arrivato primo ci sono ma
il 4 fatto 23.900 fa tevere quanto fatto
l'altra volta avevo fatto 22.154 quindi
il record quasi 24.000 punti ragazzi e
record per adesso mio e niente ragazzina
che possano chiudere qui video ovvero
che vi sia piaciuto e che abbiate capito
come funziona in questa mode che non ti
aiuta tantissimo però per lo zoom sì c'è
almeno per lo zoom serve poi per il
resto tanto la usano tutti sono solo io
deficiente in una prova
spero che vi siate 100 ragazzi cosa che
se vi è piaciuto lasciato un commento mi
piace anche la pace di facebook e come
nei video totale iscrizione sono siti si
davano questo video di fede ragazzi